América Latina y el Caribe fue la región
con más homicidios del mundo otra vez en
2022 para inside crime el narcotráfico
la fragmentación de grupos criminales y
el tráfico ilegal de armas están entre
las principales causas El Caribe es una
zona crítica las Islas turcas y caicos
tienen una tasa de 77,6 homicidios por
cada 100.000 habitantes con un aumento
de más del doble de asesinatos respecto
a 2021 esto debido al terror sembrado
por bandas jamaiquinas le sigue
precisamente Jamaica con una tasa de
homicidios de 52,9 por cada 100.000
habitantes por primera vez en tres años
no registra la tasa más alta del mundo
Aunque sus números siguen siendo
alarmantes sobre todo por el tráfico de
armas preocupa también la situación en
Haití aunque no hay registros oficiales
la ONU señala Un aumento de las muertes
en un
35,2%, con las pandillas controlando la
capital Puerto Príncipe
la situación en el Continente también es
preocupante con Venezuela en cabeza con
40 homicidios por cien mil habitantes
esto significa 26 muertes al día en un
país que tiene múltiples
microestructuras callejeras Honduras que
redujo en cerca de un 13% los asesinatos
respecto a 2021 sigue siendo el más
mortal de Centroamérica y Colombia
registra altas tasas de homicidios en
las regiones con presencia de conflicto
armado algo contra lo que el presidente
Gustavo Petro Busca terminar con su
proyecto de paz total
el informe de inside crane destaca
especialmente dos países Ecuador que
aumentó un 82% la tasa de homicidios en
un crecimiento ligado a los niveles
históricos de cocaína que ingresaron al
país desde Colombia Mientras que el
Salvador Tuvo una drástica reducción por
la guerra contra las pandillas del
presidente nayib bukele que sin embargo
ha ido de la mano de múltiples denuncias
de violación a los Derechos Humanos